كما نتابع في الصوره من خلفنا جهود تعويم
السفينه قبل حوالي 20 دقيقه بدات تثمر
وبدانا نشاهد حركه للسفينه تم تحريك
السفينه همم وابتعدت قليلا عن الساحل الذي
جنحت اليه في الساعه السابعه والنصف
بتوقيت اسطنبول الرابعه والنصف بتوقيت
جرينتش طبعا جنوح السفينه لم يؤدي الي الى
اي اضرار سواء السفينه فقط عطلت الملاحه
او حركه الملاحه في مضيق الوصفور بين همم
بحر مرمره والبحر الاسود في كلا الاتجاهين
طبعا السفينه كما تعلم خالد تحمل 13,000
تكون من البازلاء وكانت متجهه من اوكرانيا
الى ميناء مرسي اثناء وبعد دخولها من مضيق
البوسفور من جهه البحر الاسود وتوجهها
باتجاه بحر مرمره جنحت هذه السفينه هنا في
منطقه بيكوز همم منذ الساعه السابعه
والنصف تقريبا وحتى الساعه 11:30 ولا نصف
ساعه من الان كانت الجهود مستمره لكن دون
نتيجه لكن همم اعتبارا من حوالي نصف ساعه
او 20 دقيقه تقريبا بدات الجهود تثمر
وبدات السفينه تتحرك همم في مضيق البوسفور
بواسطه ثلاث قاطرات للسحب همم او ثلاثه
ثلاثه صفر للسحب بدات تحرك السفينه باتجاه
مضيق الوصفور تحركت السفينه بشكل معقول
وابتعادت قليلا عن الشاطئ المحاولات ما
تزال مستمره لاعادتها الى المسار الصحيح
بحسب ما ذكر اسطنبول فانه هناك عطل في همم
دفه او في همم الاجهزه التي تتحكم همم
توجيهها هذه السفينه همم وما زالت السلطات
او السفن همم تحاول حل هذا الموضوع كما
ذكرت همم الجهود بدات تثمر همم في همم حال
هذه المشكله قبل حوالي نصف ساعه ما زلنا
متابعنا همم
هذه الجهود معكم مباشره على شاشه العربيه
وكيف تحاول السفن جير هذه السفينه بعيدا
عن ساحل بيكوز في الجانب الاسيوي من مدينه
اسطنبول همم على مضيق البوسفورد من
المتوقع اذا استمرت هذه الامور على ما هو
عليه اذا استمر الوضع على ما هو عليه
سنشاهد تحرك السفينه خلال وقت قصير جدا
يعني ما شاهدناه قبل ان نكون معكم ان
السفينه تحركت بشكل معقول وشكل جيد طول
هذه السفينه 142 مترا وهي سفينه شحن ضخمه
لا شك لذلك السلطات التركي لاسباب امنيه
ايقاف الحركه او حركه الملاحه تماما في
مضيق الوصفور باستثناء طبعا الدوريات
والزوارق الدوريات الامنيه التي تجوب هذا
همم الساحل لضمان عدم مرور اي سفن او همم
حتى سفن نقل ما بين الضفتي الباسور الضفه
الاوروبيه او ال- الاسيويه لذلك همم نزلنا
ان نتابع معكم على الهواء مباشره هذا همم
هذه الجهود او جهود تعويم هذه السفينه همم
من المتوقع او تعمل السلطات التركيه هل
هذا الموضوع بشكل كبير لانه هناك عشرات
السفن ما زالت تنتظر في بحر مرمره وايضا
في البحر الاسود اذانا بالسماح لها
بالدخول الى مضيق الوصفه ومضيق البوسفور
الى وجهتها النهائيه كما اذا كانت واعيد
واذكر بان هذه السفينه التي كانت تقل
البازلاء من الموانئ همم الاوكرانيه كانت
تتجه الى ميناء مرسيين